hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast mesenchymal stromal or
stem cell MSE workflow for efficient
clinical translation from automated GMP
compliance cell manufacturing to
standardized phenotype assignment of
labyrinths and I'll be your moderator
for today's events today's educational
web seminar is brought to you by lab
roots and sponsored by Milton E biotech
for more information on our sponsor
please visit WWE TLC it started I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation to do so
simply type the mid-city
ask a question box and click on the send
button
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the support
tab found at the top right of the
presentation window report your problems
by clicking on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credit I'd like
to now introduce our presenter Katherine
godhardt the project manager of research
and development at Milton T biotech for
a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
Katherine you may now begin your
presentation
okay thank you very much for the
introduction I'm happy to present you
today this webinar for him and I would
like to talk about the million comments
from ourselves workflow for efficient
clinical translation
so this is first our disclaimer and I
continue now with some interesting facts
regarding Malini biotech
so the company was founded in 1989 and
up to now we have brought about 3,000
employees worldwide from about 15
different nations so it's quite an
international company I am part of the
R&D department as these are about 23% of
all the employees so we have developed
during all the years up to 70,000
different products in different research
region and also into in the clinical
field so that up to now round about
65,000 cell therapy procedures have been
taken place using multi biotic products
so about 2,500 patients were treated per
year with their products using our
technology
so that shows you all that our passion
is to have a nice product portfolio from
bench to bedside so all the products we
have support researchers all over the
world in the research field but also in
their way to go into the clinic later on
to the part of the MSC workflow we would
like to talk about today so the improved
film and see no free cultivation
solution I would like to focus on now so
first to come to the MSC workflow which
is yeah worked on at many different labs
all over the world so starting with the
sample the primary tissue so bone marrow
adipose tissue umbilical cord all these
tissues are quite barring some amazing
chemist Ramos stem cells these cells are
separated for example by different
markers or by plastic adherence further
this year theses are circuitry expanded
in large scale or small scale some
quality control is done those different
functions are analyzed and later on the
final cell product is may be preserved
or directly used for the different
applications
so what Melanie is doing is that we are
providing a lot of different products to
support this MSE workflow and even here
it's quite important for us to have the
seamless translation from basic rich
research to clinical research
and to show you and more in more details
how this look like I would like to focus
on the MSD isolation and expansion so
always questions come up so what is
needed to overcome challenges when
working in MSc field and the main
problems here are the improvement of
cell culture products to have better
methods for expansion of MSDS and to get
some help in complying with the relevant
GMP guidelines or regulation so we are
focusing here to support all these needs
and therefore we have developed
different cell culture media's for MSC
isolation and expansion for example we
have these FCS containing media and also
zina free media so Zeno and theorem free
media and I would like to point out that
we have one medium in a GMP grade to
support also all the higher regulated
needs and to to show here one very
important feature so if the customer or
if researchers start in the research
field they can use the sino free stem
max MSC expansion media XF which is yeah
you know and there are free no additives
are necessary here for a teen of MSC s
to the plastic so no coating of surfaces
and we have the same formulation are
also available as a GMP version of this
media so even this media is also seen
when theorem and also phenol red free
oh it's supporting an efficient
expansion of human MSE from different
tissue sources also from the primary
tissue
no substrate precoding of the culture
wizards is required
and as you can see here we are flexible
a bag sizes available so this is the 2
liter bag which you can see on picture
with corresponding supplements and also
a 500 milliliter bag is is provided
this medium was developed and compliant
with relevant GMP guidelines designed
following the recommendations of USP
10:43 on ancillary materials and it's
manufactured and tested under an easily
13485 compliant quality management
system
so I'd like to show now some more
details about our quality analysis of
this media so we have done a lot of
experiments here to show that MSDS are
working quite nice after expansion so
first here we wanted to show how the
chlorogenic potential looks like of our
stem marks ms exf medium as well as the
GMP version of this medium the MSE brew
GMP medium in comparison to the home
brew alpha ma'am and dmem
media as well as the comparison to two
commercially available Circassian media
so as you can see here mainly
commercially available media needs some
input of AD serum to support the
appearance of MSC s coming from primary
tissue this is not the case for our
stomachs XF and the MSC brew medium so
we have better MSC at even results in a
higher number of CF u.s. colonies using
the stem X medium and DMS Ebru and
furthermore there is a better MSE
proliferation resulting in larger
colonies so the beside the number of
colonies we have analyzed here the
number of MSC s within one dish this is
depicted within the dots in this graphic
and yes as you can see here the military
media are supporting the proliferation
even at the beginning of the culture
quite nice
so if you are interested in a clinical
scale expansion of MSC so so to say
about generating two hundred thousand
two hundred million MSC's it's possible
to do this quite fast so just within 15
days starting with ten milliliter of
human bone marrow using the stomach's
medium and DMS Ebru you reach this high
number of cells compared to the homebrew
DMM and also main media which takes a
lot more so more than three weeks wound
about to get this high number of cells
so the positive effect here that we
achieve a clinical scale MSC number with
less media consumption so we are just
using 50 to 70 percent of the media
which is normally used for homebrew
media and the reason for that is because
we are saving about yeah 14 days 15 days
after reaching this high number of MSDS
with the MS EBU GMP media but not only
this low messaging cultivation process
is optimal we also looked for
large-scale expansion so also for higher
passages so MST Boojum P medium allows
for stable expanding of emesis here we
have looked for this for up to six
passages and yeah the proliferation
range is quite nice quite comparable
with all both MLT new media and its
improved compared to the homebrew alpha
mem and dmem media but what's going on
with the cells then after expansion so
of course this is a question how
functional are the cells so therefore we
have done some functional
phase one of course very important topic
is the expression of MSE specific
surface markers for this purpose we have
used the MSE phenotyping kit flow
cocktail including different markers to
stay in cell surface and antigens
analyte and by flow cytometry and we can
show here that the relevant MSC markers
are expressed by the cells even yeah
also the differentiation media were used
for differentiation capability so for a
depuis side differentiation osteoblast
differentiation and chandra side
differentiation what is also quite
interesting for many researchers it the
immune model Ettore potential of MSE s
after difference after expansion so here
we use the MSE suppression inspector to
look for the t says suppressive
potential of MSE s and as you can see
here the potential is quite preserved
and quite high compared to the homebrew
media shown here in this graphic
what this new here is we have updated
the MSC phenotyping kit and here now I
would like to show you in more detail
how standardized and reliable this
phenotyping cocktail is
so the design of the MSA phenotyping kit
is as follows so you can do around about
50 tests with one kit the kit is
consisting of an MSA phenotyping
cocktail and an ISO type cocktail as
well as six individual antibodies for
compensation control so this is quite
important to get a reliable result at
the end
the phenotype in cocktail contains all
the relevant MSC markers CD 73 c d 9 t
CD 105 as well as the non MSC markers
and the HLA dr as recommended by the ICT
consortium so it facilitates
standardized and reliable phenotyping of
cultured human MSE from different tissue
sources
this is just one example showing human
MSC's cultured in stem max MSC excess
medium and analyzed by the MSC phenotype
inc it showing a high expression of
steady 273 90 and 105 the non MSC
markers are negative and which is also a
nice feature that the HLA dr antibody
which is in most cases also a negative
negatively expressed on the cells can be
analyzed with a separate color here and
this is quite important because
sometimes ms es are stimulated like you
can see here so the stimulation can be
done by antiphon gamma or TNF alpha to
have a look of the MSC function in more
detail but sometimes it's also the case
when for example in FCS containing media
a high amount of interferon gamma is
present then sometimes the hlad our
signal is quite high so therefore it's
really nice to have this marker with a
separate color here in this kit to
analyze it separately from the other non
MSC markers because as you see here
before stimulation it's negative and
after stimulation with interferon gamma
and TNF alpha the signal is quite high
the hybridoma antibodies are quite an
old technology they were used in the old
antibody kits so these technologies from
1970 antibodies are produced as a
hybridoma in Mouse and then later on in
the hybridoma cell culture so the new
way to produce antibodies in a
recommended way using here our riff-raff
init the antibodies is based on a system
of mammalian cell production system
producing recombinant antibodies
antibodies convicting partly of human
and mouse part and there you have some
benefits of these real Finity antibodies
for cell analysis so first they are
recommended generated and they have one
universal IgG one isotype that improves
of course the reproducibility of the
essays in the lab later on furthermore
there is a mutation mutated FC region
and these improves or reduces the
background signal
these the kid is quite easy to use the
five-car antibody cocktail includes
three positive and five negative
antibodies for MSC phenotyping in
addition and isotype control cocktail
and six individual antibodies for
compensation control are also included
the SA is very standardized because
antibodies are included that are defined
by the ICT consortium for MSD
characterization by flow cytometry
there's a really high lock to lock
consistency and repute reproducibility
because all the used antibodies are a
affinity recombinant antibodies
ticket is very reliable because we use
different flow chromes for the HLA dr
antibody to distinguish between
activated and non-activated MSC's
I would like to come up now to a next
topic so which is sorting MSC's by the
Mexican title
so sorting sells beer several problems
so for example when you sort cells with
a cell sorter there's high pressure and
shear stress affecting the viability and
function of cells decontamination
cleaning of fluidics required after each
run there is a high chance of carryover
between different runs and even when you
are when we are talking here about these
rare cells carryover is quite an
important topic adjustment of drug delay
and laser alignment is needed so the
decompression of cells affect viability
and functionality application of charge
effects viability and function admite of
and might alter gene expression safety
concerns due to errors or forming or
alternatively working under huge
biosafety cabinet
contamination of the sample effects
downstream processing so all these these
points are quite problematic and
therefore we have now the max quantizer
it's with its unique feature so it's
really gentle to the cells because it
has very low pressure no decompression
enables resorting of functional cells
and we have no cell loose in tubing sets
because the whole procedure takes place
in the cartridge and all cells are
remaining in this cartridge the max plan
title is fully serious
so cartridge provides a closed system so
the cartridge system also gives some
opportunity not to have any carryover
from experiment to experiment because
you need and use a separate cartridge
for each experiment and do we do not
have any contamination of fluidics
so it's fully safe system the absence of
aerosol and droplets and no biosafety
cabinet is needed the device is really
easy to use so it's a benchtop device no
adjustment of drop delay or laser
alignment needed and no cleaning
required
you
so this cell sorting process here at the
title is shown in more detail in this
picture so you really have yeah no
pressure no charge less arrow soul or no
arrow soul development so at the end
says are quite feeling well are very
viable and not activated in any kind of
process within here so for the MSDS we
have done several experiments to use
these device the max quantizer for
sorting using CD 271 and anti MSCI 1s
specific markers expressed on MSDS
coming from bone marrow so we used bone
marrow mononuclear self fraction labeled
with DD 271 PE and anti MCSA one APC and
you can see before separation there's
this is a really really low frequency
population with only 0.04 percent and
after separation there's a really really
high enrichment of cells more than
ninety percent
the viability is quite nice and if you
then put these cells after sorting and
also compared to the situation before
sorting in culture you can see that
there is a high increase in piano genic
potential in these sorted cell
population
here we analyze the ability of cells to
expand and proliferate after the sorting
process we have passaged the cells
several times and we can show you that
the sorted cells grow in the comparable
manner but like the plastic appearances
also the mark expression is as it is as
it should be for MS ES and also here we
looked for the pieces pressure
suppression potential so it's quite
preserved and comparable before and
after sorting
you
but besides sorting of course the
cultivation process is still important
and many people would like to do here a
closed procedure and automated
procedures so therefore we are providing
the new cleaning max prodigy at your
entire culture system so GMP compliance
a manufacturing is really complex
workflow including lot of many different
processes so set preparation surface
coating say cultivation media change
harvesting and for all these processes
many different devices are are needed
and as well you are every everything has
to done in clean rooms so we will I
combine all these steps within one
machine within the clinic max prodigy to
have the integration of these various
set processing steps
so the hardware here some description on
that the clinic's prodigy platform is an
integrated and closed system for
automated set processing from starting
material to final cellular product what
we can do is sample preparation for
example the density gradient
centrifugation to isolate MSC's from
bone marrow muna from bone marrow for
example so washing is possible media
change magnetic separation set
stimulation genetic modification and
final product formulation
so the closed system from Sampat product
that is what we want so therefore we
have the single-use disposable tubing
set ste researchers at input ports there
is possibility of sterile welding for
example using the T Romo device
integrated QC sample pouches are
integrated within the tubing set to make
it easier for ya QC sampling and doing
essays in between taking in process
controls during the expansion process
so for cultivation we have several
options for the Sentra card unit you can
see it here on the right side the
surface area is around 100 square
centimeter for a tirant and non-adherent
syrup a deviation automated feeding and
harvesting processes are possible here
so we have a temperature control because
centra card unit is placed within the
device and is part of the hoe tubing set
and the device is also supporting this
eccentric head unit with defined
atmosphere so co2 for example 5% co2 10
percent co2 whatever the cultivation
will requires there's visual cell
examination possible by an integrated
microscope the microscope is also part
of the cleaning max prodigy and we have
multiple input ports for different media
or cytokines of course these 100 square
centimeters might not to be sufficient
for different for all the different
applications especially for the MSE
workflow it is not sufficient so
therefore here you customers have the
possibility to connect an external
culture whether to the tubing set and
then it's possible to have a scaleable
send manufacturing process
now coming to the tubing set its GMP
compliant and it's possible to do
through our wedding during the process
it has integrated several bags and
sample pouches for pathogen and QC it's
easy to connect an external cultivation
whether as it is shown here and via the
dead-end tube and you cannot only
connect one for example cells back to
these dead end you can also connect up
to 330 X the five layer cells text for
example
the whole tubing set is compatible with
the upcoming mini max electroporator for
gene manipulation
so showing now here and more detail the
GMP compliant MSC expanding workflow
using the cleaning max prodigy adherence
arracacha system so everything starts
again also here with the bone marrow and
the whole process then is automated
within the machine so having the density
gradient central seeding of cells um
immediate change harvesting and seeding
again in different cell culture external
circuitry levels up to the last harvest
of the target cells
so the process is quite handy and quite
optimized to reduce the manual hands-on
time so here within this process we have
reduced the hands-on time to about 70
percent
the process is not only available for
bone marrow to isolate MSC's from bone
marrow but also you can do this with
enzymatic digested umbilical cord or
enzymatic digested adipose tissue and
also here you of course find the same
reduced hands-on time because of all the
automation of the different steps
so we prepared again here some data on
using these prodigy process for
manufacturing of MSE s in large scale
from bone marrow umbilical cord and
adipose tissue and in all cases you can
see quite quite nice that with a low
amount of primary starting material
after not more than two or three
passages we end up in a quite high
amount of of ms es up to 700 million MSS
were prepared here but of course this
number can extend it of course on the
one hand by starting with a higher
amount of starting volume or extending
the cultivation period so here in these
experiments we cultivated the cells for
ya up to 14 or 15 16 days
so summing up now I am we have a
complete workflow for efficient clinical
translation
the workflow is sterile and gentle for
example for cell sorting of MSC's using
the max quantizer
we have an efficient MSE expanding with
serum-free and see no free MSE brew GMP
medium
and we have talked about the GMP
compliant MSC expansion using the
cleaning max prodigy and cell culture
system
using the MSC phenotyping kit it's
possible to do with standardized and
reliable phenotyping and analysis of MSS
after cultivation
so you see here now again the MSC
workflow and all the different solutions
we have talked about during this webbing
very not to support the MSC workflow for
example for preparation of the primary
tissue using the gentle Maxx for example
for umbilical cord dissociation for
doing the set preparation using the
cleaning Maxx prodigy or the maximum
title cell expansion using the GMP
compliant cell culture media or
different cytokines doing the quality
control using the MSC phenotyping kit
based on the flow analysis doing some
cryopreservation of cells afterwards and
then having the final product available
would like to thank you now for
attending this this workshop thank you
very much
Thank You Packer in for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
will answer as many questions as we have
time for alright let's go ahead and get
started our first question is compared
to other commercially available kits
what are the advantages of your MSP
phenotype in tip
okay so our MSC phenotyping kiddok
includes three positive markers and a
set of negative marker
including city 14c 2 2013 4 and city 45
the cocktail does not does contain pef
it's a PC and it also includes a
separate negative marker HLA dr which is
visible with another color beside the
other negative marker and this makes it
possible to analyze cells which are
stimulated or not stimulated via the HLA
dr expression of cells furthermore we
have included here quite high
standardized recomment ray affinity
antibodies which improve the reliability
and the specifically of this antibody
cocktail
great thank you okay next question says
do you have other kicks or antibodies to
test the function of cultured MSC
so yes we have so beside the phenotyping
or the mark expression a lot of people
in the field are interested in analyzing
in the immune model Ettore potential of
MS ES and here we are providing the MSE
suppression inspector this is a kid to
look for the potential of MS es to
suppress t-cell proliferation and this
is quite a very important function of M
SES and necessary for a lot of different
clinical applications where MS CS are
currently investigated in furthermore
beside the suppression inspector we are
providing differentiation media for
adipocyte differentiation of the blast
differentiation and chondrocyte
differentiation
great thank you now in your opinion for
which application sorting approach is
helpful and can you give us an example
okay yeah I think so the sorting of MSE
s is very important in all cases where
you would like to analyze the primary
MSE s in more detail so the primary MSS
which are in the primary tissue in the
bone marrow in the adipose tissue or in
the umbilical cord for example because
here and this tissue with the MSC number
is really really really low so as we
have seen in the presentation before the
NA frequency is round about 0.01 to 0.05
percent round about and to analyze these
cells in more detail sorting approach is
quite helpful for example if you would
like to do gene array analysis or
something comparable with these primary
msys so only with this sorting sorting
approach you get a high purity of these
uncultivated untouched cells
and there are different markers which
can be used for this approach for
example CD 271 and the MSA 1 of course
another another reason why people would
like to sort MSS is of course if they
have defined a specific antibody for a
subpopulation of MSC's primary MSDS or
cultured emesis this could be another
interesting example for a sorting
approach
we have time for one more question and
we will finish with this question can
you talk a little bit more about cell
mils using your platform to culture MSC
s and to what extent can you upscale the
system
okay sorry can we repeat this question I
came yeah
please repeat this question
sure
can you talk a bit more about cell yield
using your platform to culture MSC and
the second part of the question says to
what extend can you upscale the system
okay yeah that's also a good question so
in our experiments we have cultured the
MSC's from the different tissues to up
to 700 million cells and for this
approach we have used six a two or three
five layer steps depending on the
starting material but of course it could
be up scared even more so if you would
like to start with a higher amount of
cells at the beginning or to continue
the cultivation period even then you can
extend the whole system by using six
five layers text and these would then
result in a surface area of about twenty
thousand square centimeters
but I'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their questions
any questions we did not have time for
today and most submitting during the day
on demand periods will be addressed by
the speaker via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
we would like to once again thank
Katherine for her time today and her
important research we would also like to
thank lab roots and our sponsor melanie
biotechs
for underwriting today's educational
webcast this webcast can be viewed
on-demand laberd's will alert you via
email when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye